[Music]
what happens here in Southern
California's people break rules right
I'm another taco like my mom making
house lettuce and tomato and cheese
that's it
it's a black hole mates I thought the
way we rap the way we live the way we
dress everybody takes our culture or why
can't we do the same if they can do
Chinese tacos in the San Gabriel Valley
why not african-american topics in South
LA we get together we gonna tear the
[ __ ] no matter how many in and out
burgers and avocado toast you may see on
your Instagram feed don't get it twisted
la is a taco town tortillas filled with
al Pastore Korean barbecue sushi grade
tuna
they are fueling the streets and the
folks who are making them depend on this
taco mania basically for their
livelihoods now lately I've been hearing
about a new coalition a new collective
of young entrepreneurs there in Compton
there in South LA there in watts and not
only are they taking that taco and re
mixing it but they're creating their own
new food movement I'm all about it and I
want to know more
[Music]
the 92 riots were a watershed moment in
the history of my life Latinos were
immigrating to suffer late large numbers
and and really after the rise a lot of
sort of middle-class and
african-american folks started to move
out of some of it
places that have traditionally for
generations been african-american are
now african-american / Latino and at
some point it makes sense they're gonna
start to be curious about each other's
foods I think it was only a matter of
time right that African American folks
started to make tacos to me it
symbolizes this historic cultural
exchange that has always happened when
you have different groups living in a
similar community right out of this
cultural exchange a new african-american
taco movement is growing one that's less
about fusion food and more about the
powers of self branding now leading the
charge are folks like Keith Garrett aka
all flavor no grease starting from
nothing but a griddle in his Watts
driveway he's amassed a huge social
media following drawing everybody from
local gang members to first-time la
tourists but before he became known as a
quesadilla legend it was the taco the
kick started his lucrative hustle gonna
open up at five o'clock Taco Tuesday
going up
chuckles came after I was finished
selling wheat cuz all of it started
right here to defend me the weed the
pills everything all the drugs that
started here on the same block right
here I was telling myself like Lord I'm
tired of this [ __ ] like I don't want to
sell no we don't why I'm making no money
off that you know what's what so mind
blowing is the lesson you're giving
everyone is that selling tacos has a
better profit margin than selling weed
guaranteed
is this where you first set up shop we
started right here boom daily transition
right here then we work back right there
and now what do you have a mind you
number one of 40 our food truck fleet I
miss other tacos like my mom making the
house the ground turkey or ground beef
shredded chicken breast strips came
along later without my cobbler lettuce
tomatoes cheese sour cream and we put
ketchup there hot sauce as well and I
said that's how I'm gonna sell the taco
so then once they liked it that's what
made me stay on the gas with it hey look
at my son to eat pull up on 100's tree
yeah you looking for a quesadilla taco
or burrito
tell me why you got shut down
what have the traffic be cracking too
hard you feel we got a DJ that's hard
it'd just be too late out here they
don't like that for real and the police
is maybe that is one hatin ass cop see
because these are the same police that's
been in the same jurisdiction since I
was out here on [ __ ] has watts
itself changed since the time that you
neither started a shorter shirt right
here right now this wouldn't be cracking
they would be right there chillin none
of that but every since all flavor no
grease started this is cease fire
we're both gangs right now but the OGS
from this hood and that one had a
meeting that mark I'm in the back of
Markham middle school okay man we gotta
have a ceasefire - homie over here
getting money you right we want to go
over here patronage y'all home evil
child tripping I feel I'm not tripping
we not tripping all right let's see yes
everybody eats
[Music]
to sum it all up this whole story
disfavor you fiddly favor from God
because if you do what's right you plant
the right seeds and then you win it's
inevitable to win so I'm winning
off-label agrees to me represents you
know people making the best out of a
situation in which they were they were
never intended to succeed in so it's
motivational its inspiration all flavor
no grease wasn't the only one to be
inspired by the tacos opportunities meet
Monty Blanco the designated taco lady of
trap kitchen now trap kitchen is
everything that it sounds like a wildly
popular moving food party's founded by
her friends spank and news but it's
Monty's larger-than-life personality not
a culinary degree that's bringing her
fans to her taco table with her outside
the clubs in Hollywood or in a back yard
in Compton
[Music]
Monni Blanco what's that [ __ ] to be
clear is on the hot grill yes in a tight
dress yeah he told out keeping it sexy
yeah I look good you want to get money
gotta look like Miami we are in a raisi
backyard in the middle of Compton
there's a barn there's like 10 boats
there's no water in the pool there's no
riders I mean it's kind of like a like a
taco speakeasy it's only for those in
the know tell me what do you think
they're really coming here for this for
us and our personalities in the way we
represent ourselves and then we make it
seem really poppin which we are like I
wanna hang with them and eat their food
this is not the only place that you set
up shop no no we're in Compton right now
but you're all over all over I'll be in
gardena I'll be in LA
I'll see wherever the people that do you
have an idea of what you want to do next
well I definitely want to bring
four grills on to the team and I want to
over there and bikini top serving so
over here in bikini top serving and
Beach out kitchen Angels United me with
ten thousand tacos I'll trying to bring
sexy to the taco thing yeah when I'm
talking to a lot of these guys that are
opening these new taco businesses it's a
lot of male energy it's a lot of
testosterone you're the only woman I
didn't know exactly how they were going
to receive me as being a truck kitchen
taco girl or just a black girl some
tacos on trees I don't think people will
believe you not I mean but you have to
believe in yourself as amazing this is
forever
food is forever the only time it will
die down is if your ambition dies down
with no marketing budget or outside
investors South LA's new taco
entrepreneurs rely on word of mouth and
camaraderie to drive business Jamel
Henderson had his doubters when he first
started selling tacos in Compton but
endorsements from rappers like Nipsey
Hussle and yg helped him turn his
upstart catering service
taco Mel into a thriving
brick-and-mortar location in Leimert
Park before I even started selling tacos
I was really like pregnancy with it I
had a little um electrical a little um
griddle and I was playing around like
yeah a dollar fifty tacos dollars fifty
tacos I wouldn't be suddenly I just made
a price up people's looking at like man
it looks good I mean he should sell
those nighttime lame yeah that's nothing
I can't see like I'm a black man in LA
like this is not gonna do well here
basically where you see it right here
Taco Bell when did you start you know
getting a little bit more serious with
him actually making burritos tacos
quesadillas I was like how about 21
years old my daughter was just born I
was working a security job but I just
needs that little extra money
alright homemade tacos my mom of course
but I didn't either like a Mexican taco
until I was in high school because
clearance to cross street that was my
first time having a
or nearsighted taco with the onion is
cilantro with the sauce it was crazy I
loved it I fell in love
we used lettuce and tomato and cheese
that's it a little bit of sour cream or
rare rooster black homemade side of what
is being called an african-american taco
Ilyas American crunchy tacos and soft
tacos I mean every community in the
United States has done taco night why do
you think all these artists are coming
here the same way that everybody else is
because the food is good except we play
I love that it's good to see a lot of
black businesses and go see more black
faces you know I was hearing about a
minute I saw him out Y Z video shoot and
then why everybody was getting it wisely
I just my favorite tacos right here do
you feel like you're learning how to do
social media from artists like Casey
oh yeah of course good oceans everything
you like the food game turning into the
rap yeah we thought we've been me or
fair love grease fries man but the
longing you'll swear alias rapper was in
there I think that you um you've talked
about is creating sort of like a a
coalition like a cruel yeah
fool Menotti the food will not either f
what do we have right here no Menotti
Minardi you here we coming for you baby
daddy I came up with the name from the
gate then I told Craig mr. fireman he
fumbled or enough The Fool of what what
to see it a fool monatti I'm just here
not the Illuminati then we're not
sacrificing nobody none of that
I'm chef LJ I'm with the blue kitchen
this is my boy demo blue kitchen
DJ bowtie fly hello mr. fries me you
know the mail burrito understand the
flavor naughty why is this the takeover
wise is the future we dive down from
this Monterrey we over me over me
because there's a negative stereotype in
the black community saying that we're
crabs in a barrel and this right here is
showing people that we think outside of
it and how does it feel for you guys to
not only feed your community but also to
see yourselves as entrepreneurs because
you're setting an example there
everybody like it's not just sports
entertainment it's bigger than that the
world is much bigger than copy it is a
deep sense of community not competition
that has fueled these entrepreneurs and
given them the resources to become
self-sufficient ultimately they're on a
mission to introduce the world to South
LA one taco at a time I think these
artists have formed a collective like
artists do and I think they help build a
culture and a genre that we will see
expanded throughout the country
eventually the fact that there's a
movement going on in South Los Angeles
and the fact that it doesn't necessarily
have you know the piercing eye of the
nation's PD on and maybe a good thing I
mean I let it can develop it can develop
its own tropes you can develop its own
story
taco mills are flavor no greets mr. fry
blues kitchen these are the underground
hip-hop you heard a real artist
[Music]